today we're checking out the legend case
cooking's cooking tutorial i am going to
replicate it while i survive we'll just
gonna have to find out i decided to
follow cave's spaghetti bolognese recipe
the day keeps cooking uploaded that
video she changed cooking forever okay
so i watched case cooking
they look so disgusting i am baffled how
she made it look so gross i'm sorry k
i'm sorry so i wanted to see
can i
make it look that gross without trying
is it a certain skill that she has
we're gonna have to find out let's
follow the recipe
[Music]
there it is they're beautiful i watched
to see what rest of what ingredients we
had so i'm going to
first of all
all right let's beat some eggs up
i've never seen anyone break an egg with
a fork but maybe
yeah
it works
that actually works pretty well hey
katie's cooking got it right all this
time maybe and then she stirred them
around
lovely usually you separate right like i
never seen you know what i don't i don't
know
and i've got some spaghetti sticks here
oh spaghetti
i also have spaghetti sticks
why does she call it spaghetti sticks i
don't know spaghetti
it's not spaghetti sticks i like that
she added oh no
this is a big deal for me because
i am
a pescetarian i am 20 better than
everyone it's something i lived with
many years and i'm gonna break that just
for the sake of this stupid case cooking
video i got some beef some proper beef
mince this is the power case cooking
have over me i honestly i don't
it's kind of gross
but let's do it it wouldn't be a cage
cooking video otherwise
nice so we have the mints and then she
mix the the egg inside
i probably need more oh god
this is not k's cooking's fault but i'm
so repulsed by this this is so nasty
like whenever i watch vegans try
meat and stuff and they're all like oh
it's so gross i kind of get it this is
super nasty i need more egg but i you
know that's the point of case cooking it
goes beyond
food oh god
why does she put egg in everything you
can't just keep adding egg to stuff kate
so gross dude all right
all right that's enough egg
i've got some spaghetti sticks she
brings out the spaghetti sticks
yeah whatever i don't even know how to
do this i've seen some video but i don't
even know how to do it she doesn't know
how to do it
that makes two of us k
oh my god
i think i definitely added too much egg
on mine but let's see how this goes
normally i would add some oven paper on
this but kay doesn't put oven paper so
i'm not going to put oven paper either
let me grab my
spaghetti sticks i don't know how many i
think this is a healthy amount and then
what she did was
she
yeah
let's go
okay
wow
holy wow
oh no that's not gonna work we're gonna
have to ah
yeah
kind of like that how does that look
that's not too bad give it a good
squeeze mmm
yummy yummy yummy
so good
oh god
oh forbidden pasta if my tech comes in
right now boy
it'd be trouble let's see one more i
think i got kb like mine don't even look
that bad honestly how does she do it she
is a true culinary genius monsieur look
at this
it's beautiful
what what was that sound
that all the earlier italians get sucked
out what do you mean what do you i don't
get it what's the problem
don't leave
okay
she will love it it's not done yet
there we go
looking good so she puts tomato sauce
and then she chops onions
okay
so
tomato sauce do i have it all right
let's
[Music]
sprinkle it not all of it she said not
all of it so let's be careful all right
so this will go in the oven for 20
minutes
let's go all right next up we're gonna
chop some onion now you're not supposed
to do that on a wooden cut board but i
didn't have anything else so
that's fine five second caves kitchen
rule onion is such a pet peeve of mine
because i i like the taste of it but i
don't like the consistency so i would
always chop onion into like baby pieces
at the point where they are
they're practically obliterated because
uh that's just the way i like it but um
that's not the k
k kitchen way
[Applause]
all right what's next
[Music]
so she's following a recipe who the hell
made this recipe okay
someone
oh god
all right let's have a look to see how
they're doing
honestly this doesn't look bad i don't
know how she does it
god damn it i've failed
it doesn't look repulsive all right
we'll see how they come out they need 10
more minutes
it's time
oh boy it's the first time i get to
experience case cooking the lovely aroma
oh god
let's go
let's have a look good it's bad boy
that's what i'm talking about
oh boy
nice
oh god
seeing it up close it's so beautiful
marzia
and look at these she's throwing a pot
she's making the patri all right she's
missing out so sprinkle next step is to
sprinkle the onion
people say british cooking isn't nice
cookie is changing the game mate all
right that's enough for me at least
so
next you're supposed to cover it with
tomato sauce the rest and to make sure
it's all covered so i'm doing that now
they say you can cover in whatever spice
you want k use oregano so i'm gonna use
oregano is it oregano or oregano or is
it who gives a whoa that's a bit much
you should just look at it it smells
good right
you like that you don't like it
yeah
it's got 20 more
i feel like you don't mean it
what do you think of this what do you
think that is what i was looking at
how dare you
alright so
this is going in for another 20 minutes
it seems like a lot of effort for
something that it looks like it does
[Music]
it's been 20 minutes it's time for the
big reveal
all right
here it is
why does he not look horrible what does
kate do what is her secret size
what do you mean why do you make that
face
oh the sauce egg what do you think eggy
eggy do you want some cakes cooking no
it doesn't even look that bad i need to
get closer it's so burnt what do you
mean burn spaghetti do you not see it
it's called burnt it's a spaghetti it's
a burn
try to separate them me and again we
don't see any problem
yeah it kind of separates
look at that
i can't wait to try
especially this part that looks
wonderful
oh oh
oh look at how the meat cooked
oh oh why is it gray oh that's nasty eww
okay let's eat it k doesn't show like
how oh my god it's all burnt
stuck to the
there it is
why is the meat gray do you think i'll
die this is such a curse
you know people wanted cooking with
pewdiepie back i don't know if this is
maybe this is what people actually
wanted hey look at this look at this
look at it look at me five-star
restaurant do you think i could start
this i mean i can't wait
[Applause]
can i not have it
[Music]
we love your cooking just for the record
so it's all love all right here we go
i'm breaking my
pescetarianism here for this video this
is a big deal i'm actually thinking is
it okay if i don't eat the meat because
i feel like i'm gonna get sick but let's
start let's start with the spaghetti bit
oh my god
sign show them
showcase um the guy that
tested it
because you could hear it's crunchy but
he seemed completely unfazed by it
[Music]
i will say beyond the crunchiness and
uncookedness it ain't that bad some
parts are actually cooked wow
well there you have it folks case
cooking i actually i will not eat the
meat i'll refuse i don't care call me
put though you want let me know what you
want me to cook next time leave a like
if you enjoyed this video and subscribe
and hit the bell button can i give a tag
girl just a tiny bit
[Music]
okay okay
how could you do this
well there you have it folks beautiful